[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de francés 24
en este programa el tema es la lucha
contra la violencia de género en eeuu el
presidente joe by the pidió
recientemente que el congreso actúe sin
retraso para aprobar la ley contra la
violencia machista el acto que protege a
las víctimas en el seno de su hogar y
que ataque a las diferentes formas de
acoso y de abuso en las que
frecuentemente los niños son los más
perjudicados en juego está la salud
física y mental su derecho a una vida
digna y en los casos son más extremos su
vida
en qué consiste la ley a quienes protege
y porque no hay tiempo que perder veamos
el congreso de eeuu tiene un compromiso
con las mujeres para protegerlas de la
violencia machista
solo puedo pensar en todos aquellos a
quienes sus abusadores han hecho sentir
impotentes por un sistema que no los
protegió padres cuyos hijos han sido
asesinados por una pareja abusiva
mujeres que sufren violencia doméstica y
sin embargo no se les cree niños que han
sufrido traumas que les cambiaron la
vida y estrés postraumático en manos de
las personas más cercanas a ellos
a mediados de febrero la actriz angelina
jolie abogó por que vuelva a entrar en
vigor la ley de la violencia contra la
mujer el mismo día un grupo de senadores
demócratas y republicanos llegaron a un
acuerdo bipartidista para impulsar la
originalmente impulsada por joe biden
cuando era senador en 1994 fue la
primera ley de eeuu sobre la violencia
contra las mujeres periódicamente
refrendada hasta que en 2019 se quedó
frenada opacada por debate sobre el
porte de armas combatir la violencia
doméstica el asalto sexual la violencia
entre personas que están en una relación
y el acoso no debería ser un tema de
demócratas o republicanos es un asunto
de justicia y compasión desde los 90
cuando entró en vigencia por primera vez
las cifras oficiales muestran un
descenso del 50% en los casos de
violencia en el seno de la pareja en el
país
pero la violencia machista afecta
todavía un tercio de las estadounidenses
según los reportes conocidos
ahora el gobierno resalta que aumentarán
los esfuerzos de prevención y el acceso
a servicios legales así como la
formación de las autoridades policiales
y judiciales la ley también incluirá
medidas de apoyo a supervivientes lgtb
más y para conversar sobre el tema está
con nosotros alejandra cárdenas
directora de las estrategias globales
legales del centro de derechos
reproductivos en nueva york' alejandra
un gusto saludarla nuevamente y
bienvenida a ella soy
un grupo guapo para comenzar le quiero
preguntar cuál es el nivel de
desprotección para las mujeres y para
los niños por el vacío de una ley contra
la violencia
bueno es importante recalcar que esto es
un tema sobre todo de faltar recursos es
decir los programas y los servicios en
su mayoría siguieron funcionando pero
han seguido funcionando como decimos por
lo que hay gente con las uñas porque lo
que hizo la reautorización de la ley de
nuevo fue quitarle entonces sus recursos
a esos servicios a sus programas
entonces para que un ejemplo muy
concreto en lugares donde no hay
recursos ni siquiera para comprar un kit
por ente para hacer un examen
a una persona que ha sido violada
sexualmente entonces si no hay ni
siquiera un kit para hacer un examen
coherencia y no se pueden recabar las
pruebas necesarias para después obtener
justicia en el sistema judicial entonces
son cosas tan básicas como esas que
pueden truncar por completo el acceso a
la justicia de las personas
reuters que son como lugares de paso de
acogida en donde van las las personas
que están siendo víctimas de violencia
doméstica por ejemplo donde pueden pasar
una época con sus hijos estar seguras de
que no van a ser victimizada nuevamente
pero muchos de estos sitios han tenido
que recortar el número de personas que
reciben
las posibilidades de servicios que
pueden pensar que hemos tenido los
recursos para hacerlo entonces realmente
es muy muy grave que se haya frenado ya
por dos años y tres la autorización de
esta ley y se haga queda sin recursos
todos estos programas y servicios bueno
alejandra y usted doblaban hace un
momento de la violencia doméstica porque
la violencia de género no puede ser un
asunto familiar
bueno no es un asunto familiar porque la
violencia no es un asunto privado o sea
la violencia es
un tema que afecta a todo el mundo en la
sociedad y pues es un tema de violación
de derechos humanos o sea si yo no puedo
tener mi vida mi integridad personal mi
salud respetada sea en el ámbito que sea
pues yo tengo derecho a que el estado
intervenga y prevenga problemas luego
intervenga si sucedió para que haga una
investigación y una sanción y una
protección de la persona y sus
familiares más allegados para que no
puedan ser revictimizadas
reutilizadas y está la tarea que desde
la especialidad de usted la vio la
violencia y los derechos reproductivos
cómo se ven vulnerados a partir de la
pérdida de protección por esta ley que
todavía no ha sido refrendada
bueno además entre más tiempo pasa una
persona con su abusador sobre todo en
casos de violencia modifican menos
control tiene sobre su capacidad
reproductiva
lo que vemos muchas veces es que mujeres
en situaciones y ciclos de violencia
terminan teniendo el mayor número de
hijos más de los que quisieran y podrían
porque sus parejas no les permiten tener
autonomía con con sobre su capacidad
productiva pues obviamente esto es muy
grave muchas veces lleva a que las
mujeres en situaciones de mucha
desesperación acudan a abortos inseguros
y entre tanto pues el otro tema que
llama la atención alejandra en este caso
es que joe biden ha destacado mucho que
con la nueva refrendación de la ley si
se logra este año se va a incluir un
punto que es es para la protección de
las comunidades diversas para los el gti
cumas y usted qué opina de esta
inclusión
me parece fabuloso y esto va más allá
algunas protecciones que ya existían en
las versiones anteriores de la ley
para la comida de tvi pero esta versión
no sería más expansiva y tendría unas
protecciones especiales para la
comunidad trans y pues esto es muy muy
importante muy necesario porque por
supuesto que también hay violencia
doméstica y violencia de género dentro
de estas comunidades y hacia estas
comunidades entonces es apenas lógico
que si uno de verdad tiene un compromiso
serio con proteger a las personas de
esta violencia que se incluya a todas
las comunidades y en esta oportunidad
también se están primando protecciones
especiales para las comunidades tribales
o indígenas eso también es fundamental
y ahí hay sin embargo un vacío o algo
que la menta puede ser presidente que
recordemos fue la persona que impulsó en
su momento la ley como senador y es que
existe este llamado vacío legal del
novio entonces cuando hay hombres que
cometen actos de violencia contra las
mujeres sus parejas o los miembros de su
familia les prohíben por ejemplo el
porte de armas pero esto no aplica
cuando no es
una pareja digamos de hecho solamente
aplica para el esposo para el papá qué
decir sobre esto
bueno es una vergüenza realmente que
tantos senadores se hayan opuesto y haya
terminado siendo negociado ese punto de
la ley es un punto que ha estado en
controversia desde hace mucho tiempo y
en general los miembros y los y las
congresistas del partido republicano se
han opuesto y han hecho eco de la
posición del género en la sociedad
nacional del rifle que es como la
organización que defiende el porte y uso
de armas
es una vergüenza porque por supuesto que
existe un número altísimo de violencia
doméstica perpetrada por novios o novias
o personas con las que uno está en una
situación apenas como necesita o está
saliendo y es absurdo que a estas
personas se les va a seguir permitiendo
el porte de armas cuando han cometido
este tipo de violencia pero las personas
que ya están pasando entonces no tiene
ningún sentido lógico otro que seguir
protegiendo a la industria de las armas
en este país por encima de proteger los
derechos fundamentales de las personas a
su integridad personal mire estamos
hablando de que aproximadamente desde el
inicio del 2019 esta ley dejó de tener
efecto y por lo tanto puede ser millones
de mujeres en eeuu quedaron sin la
cobertura porque en su opinión pasó
tanto tiempo a tu ha tenido que pasar
tanto tiempo para que por fin los
congresistas vuelvan a poner el foco
sobre esta ley y sobre estos servicios
que son esenciales para pues no sólo las
ciudadanas para todos los ciudadanos en
el país
desgraciadamente frecuentemente vemos
que en los derechos humanos y los
derechos de las mujeres en particular se
sacrifican muy rápidamente en el nombre
de controversias e intereses que no
deberían entrar en juego y no han habido
tres puntos en particular que han sido
siempre muy contenciosos respecto a él
uno ha sido las protecciones del
reconocimiento de la violencia en la
comunidad del gt-r y hacia la dgt y el
segundo punto que siempre ha denegado
tensión y que ha impedido que avancen
las negociaciones han sido las
protecciones hacia las personas
indocumentadas para acceder a servicios
pero también porque existen protecciones
en estas leyes en esta ley incluso en
esta versión que le permiten a las
personas víctimas de violencia doméstica
o violencia de género acceder a
a visas irregulares a su situación de
inmigración en este país y eso pues es
un tema que toca el tema migratorio y
ese es un tema que se vuelve
absolutamente
ideologizado y intenso y ha impedido que
las negociaciones avancen y el tercer
tema que ha sido una piedra en el avance
de la negociación ha sido el tema de
quitarle el porte el privilegio del
porte de armas a las personas que
cometen violencia doméstica o violencia
de género
que no están casadas con la vez lo que
hablábamos de lo de la excepción de la
gam a excepción del móvil si el vacío
total del novio pues alejandra mire
muchas gracias por aclarar todas
nuestras dudas alrededor del tema y lo
que esperamos sinceramente en ellas hoy
es que se pueda dar el curso normal para
que la ley pueda volver a entrar en
vigencia gracias a ustedes y gracias
también a nuestros televidentes por
estar con nosotros una vez más en ellas
hoy y nos vemos próximamente en france
[Música]